people are telling you to try to make
the most out of quarantine time but if
you're a comic and you don't know how to
edit like use Photoshop or final cut do
the online tutorials I mean they're
they're kind of grueling sometimes and
you have to really force yourself to
kind of sit through it and learn but
it's something that will help you long
long into your career after this is all
said and done with my best advice for
comedians going through this right now
try to find the way to scratch that itch
without being able to do stand-up if you
can do that via zoom shows or you know
online shows I would say do that I don't
necessarily like them but I'm lucky
enough that I can wait for audiences to
come back but I would also say you don't
have to release everything you do I
think we're in this weird age where
everyone wants to show you how busy they
are without actually concentrating on
making something that's really good well
I would say now is a good time to create
social media content but not but but you
have the free time to do good stuff
right I feel like everybody in the
beginning was just slamming stuff out
because they were like oh I got to get
it out I got to be the first one to talk
about the quarantine I say you can
forget all about the quarantine and just
do the content that you've always wanted
to do right now is your time remember
that your words are a magnet so what you
say will draw certain people to you and
you need to make sure that those are the
type of people you want drawn to you
don't have to do everything every
podcast every you know like don't go on
something that has fans that you don't
think are gonna love what you do or you
don't want like what you do jokes matter
I I think no matter who you are so to
say that you know to say things that
whether you're influential or not but
especially if you're influential and
have a lot of followers like they're not
just jokes what you say matters you know
the only thing we have is performing
live or that I have and so that all got
taken and so it's gone and you know
there's other ways to do stuff to be
creative if it's a newer comic it's like
because the problem is like you just
have no way to go be funny in a way and
so doing a lot of these doing
interviews or something or like where
I'm at least talking and having to be
funny and doing friends podcast that's a
good that's a good thing to do in this
time even to do one a week just to kind
of keep your chops like you know if
you're new or something that's like
trying to start a podcast right start
something think of you know find some
way to be creative be ready so when it's
time to come back you're you know ready
to go if you're serious about becoming a
comedian join our Facebook group linked
in the description below to start
getting tips like these every single day
and watch this playlist of our top
writing tips to improve your writing
today
[Music]